donc n'oubliez pas le foot et sa nation
lancé aux jeunes de la cité du parc de
vernouillet en écrit m j'en connais bien
à la pense qu'avoir professionnel est
arrivé en france il ya cinq ans pour
subir une opération des ligaments sa
carrière de joueur brive elle restera
ici chez un cousin clandestin pendant
trois ans elle ne lâchera pas dimanche
dernier un simple contrôle d'identité
suivie dans la foulée d'un avis
d'expulsion vers son pays d'origine
j'ai jamais eu de problèmes avec la
police ni avec les jeunes du quartier
j'ai toujours leur grand frère qui est à
peu près bon ils disent toujours que
sais je suis quelqu'un qui donne
toujours le bon exemple
parce que je les aime bien j'aimerais
bien rester avec nous parce que pour moi
c'est une fan
un sentiment partagé par l'ensemble de
la population de la 6éme où une
cinquantaine de jeunes accompagnés de
parents responsables d'associations ont
occupé le centre socioculturel du
parcours en plus une expulsion de cet
habitant qqun qui a passé du temps on a
énormément et on voit pas qui part en
deux qui restent à vernir ce qui
maintenant il fait partie de notre
famille fait partie de ces nos frères et
on veut qu'ils restent ici
il a quand même une équipe les moins de
13 et moins de 15
il s'en occupe et les seniors aussi et
puis bon mais c'est vrai que son équipe
très très bien c'est ce formidable
l'expulsion de joe cole vient du sénégal
est prévue juste le temps pour le maire
rpr de demander un report de trois mois
auprès du préfet un sursis pour préparer
un véritable dossier afin que les jeunes
de la cité gardent leur entraîneur de
foot